obviously there's a lot of focus on  Sydney today the Prime Minister has  already tweeted about that but his focus  will turn to domestic politics we've got  two big speeches one from David Cameron  Warren from EDD Miliband the Prime  Minister focusing firstly on housing but  also a political speech in which he's  going to attack Labour's plans on the  economy the Tories think this is their  strength but they have been hurt  recently by comparisons between their  plans and 1930 spending levels labour  meanwhile taking on the issue of  immigration and Miliband saying he will  crack down on companies that undercut  British workers by paying foreign  workers cheap wages but also a leaked  document in The Telegraph suggesting  that they've told candidates not to  focus too heavily on immigration and  instead to turn the attention onto  things that they think they're stronger  such as health